الى العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس يصل رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو للقاء
الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل المكرون وعلى
قائمه البحث التوترات المتناميه بشان
ايران السفاره الاسرائيليه في باريس قالت
ان نتنياهو سيبحث مع ماكرون الجهود
الدوليه لوقف البرنامج النووي الايراني
بالاضافه الى بحث توترات في المنطقه ويسعى
طرف الاسرائيلي خصوصا الى تركيز هذه
الزياره على موضوع ايران املا في ان يدفع
طلوع طهران المتنامي في الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا من خلال تزويد روسيا بعتاد دول
الغربيه الى تشديد الضغوط على ايران في
حين ان المحادثات بشان الملف النووي
الايراني متوقفه ترى باريس انه ينبغي
اعتماد سياسه حازمه جدا حيال ايران ومنذ
اشهر عده باتت ايران طرفا يزداد اهميه في
النزاع الاوكراني من خلال توفير مسيرات
كثيره تستخدمها موسكو لضرب المنشات
الاوكرانيه وامام هذا الانخراط المتزايد
لايران في الحرب الاوكرانيه اعلن نتنياهو
انه بات مستعدا للتفكير في تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه فيما يبدو انه تغيير كبير في موقف
اسرائيل علما انه اكد ايضا استعداده للاعب
دوري الوسيط في هذا النزاع